[Música]
el gobierno ruso expulsó al vice
embajador estadounidense y washington
criticó la medida previamente el kremlin
gay respondió de eeuu que para
desescalar las tensiones en la frontera
ucraniana es imperativo que deje de
suministrar armas a kiev y retire las
que ya fueron entregadas ampliamos desde
la capital estadounidense
francia y sus aliados anunciaron la
retirada de sus tropas de malí en un
máximo de seis meses los militares
participaban en dos operaciones de lucha
contra el terrorismo dentro de ese país
y en el sahel
ya son más de 100 los fallecidos por las
inundaciones y los deslizamientos en la
localidad brasileña de petrópolis al
norte del río de janeiro los equipos de
rescate trabajan a contrarreloj para
hallar al menos 40 personas que
continúan desaparecidas
buenas tardes para todos bienvenidos a
esta emisión de noticias en france 24
soy valentina torres sánchez iniciamos
en rusia en medio de la atención con
occidente el gobierno de vladímir putin
expulsó al vice embajador estadounidense
en moscú algo que washington calificó
como una medida no provocada y advirtió
que habrá consecuencias más temprano el
kremlin había entregado sus respuestas a
las propuestas de eeuu para desescalar
las tensiones en la frontera ucraniana y
aseguró que es necesario que washington
deje de proveerle material
armamentístico a kiev y que retire el
que ya entregó el gobierno de job
alguien pidió pruebas claras de rusia
que sigue reiterando que no busca
invadir territorio ucraniano desde la
capital estadounidense cristóbal vázquez
nos dio más detalles
brincan dijo que se presentaba en nueva
york' para empezar una guerra sino para
evitarla dijo que aunque rusia está
diciendo que está sacando las tropas de
la frontera inteligencia estadounidense
ve barcos aviones y tropas acercándose
aún más a la frontera con ucrania y dijo
que un ataque podría darse en los
próximos días sin embargo no presentó
pruebas para esto y tampoco presentó
pruebas sobre el argumento de que moscú
estaba preparando alguna pretexto para
llevar a cabo el ataque contra ucrania
al respecto también el secretario de
defensa lloyd austin dijo que se están
sumando equipos militares rusos en la
frontera dijo que se está sumando
también provisiones de sangre y que esto
no se hacía precisamente cuando un
fuerza militar se está retirando de
algún lugar alguna zona américa
vamos a francia el presidente manuel
marco anunció que en un lapso de 4 a 6
meses tanto francia como sus socios
europeos retiraran a sus tropas de malí
en una declaración conjunta marco indicó
que ya no hay condiciones políticas
operativas o jurídicas para continuar
con los compromisos militares en la zona
y destacó la falta de cooperación de la
junta militar que gobierna bamako
más temprano conversamos con isidro
sepúlveda analista internacional
especialista en geopolítica y experto en
terrorismo y crímenes de odio quien nos
explicó si puede haber efectos positivos
de esta retirada
no no no va a haber ningún efecto
positivo al contrario lo que se va a ver
es un refuerzo de la presencia
fundamentalmente de rusia en el mal y el
problema fundamental que hay en lo que
se ha producido el cambio sustancial si
es que se ha producido en los últimos
siete años es que fueron las autoridades
de malí quien pidió ayuda a la antigua
metrópoli colonial que era francia y en
ese momento el presidente francés
decidió mandar organizar esta esta
misión que no solamente en francesa sino
también de otros países europeos en los
últimos dos años ha habido dos golpes de
estado en el malí que han cambiado
totalmente la clase política y sobre
todo las prometidas elecciones no se han
celebrado las relaciones no es que
fueran hayan ido a mal han ido a peor
sino que han sido catastróficas de hecho
las autoridades militares de madrid
expulsaron al propio embajador francés
el 30 de enero consecuencia
al borde de una ruptura diplomática
entre las partes
lo que nos encontramos en este momento
es la sustitución de buena parte del
nivel máximo de seguridad de mali de las
tropas francesas a la compañía va a ser
de mercenarios rusos y esto es un cambio
de geopolítica y
rusia tratando de incrementar su peso
estratégico el mal
justamente en este contexto sin la
participación de malí la unión europea y
la unión africana iniciaron una cumbre
de dos días en la que buscan mejorar la
relación entre ambos bloques en ámbitos
como la seguridad y la lucha contra el
terrorismo se prevé que del encuentro
salga un plan de acción para 2030
apoyado en un plan de la unión europea
para movilizar a áfrica
150.000 millones de euros en inversiones
públicas y privadas
vamos ahora américa latina brasil
continúa en los trabajos de búsqueda y
rescate de posibles sobrevivientes de
los deslizamientos de tierra e
inundaciones ocurridos en la localidad
de petrópolis ubicada a unos 70
kilómetros al norte de río de janeiro
las autoridades mantienen el estado de
alerta en la zona al tiempo que reportan
más de 100 muertos por la situación más
en el informe de luis mendez zúrich
una escena de guerra así quedó la ciudad
de petrópolis en la zona montañosa del
estado de río de janeiro en brasil las
precipitaciones producto del paso de una
tormenta provocaron deslizamientos de
tierra e inundaciones que sorprendieron
a los habitantes del lugar los equipos
de rescate no han detenido el trabajo
para encontrar sobrevivientes de la
tragedia los lugares equipos son mis
cuatro hogares
dubai para pues los equipos trabajan las
24 horas no van a parar las búsquedas
van a seguir a menos que los técnicos
digan que deben parar una o dos horas
dependiendo del volumen de las lluvias
pero en condiciones normales no parada
nos magna normalidad nos no sé para nada
el pasado 15 de febrero la zona recibió
en unas horas el equivalente a las
precipitaciones de un mes en medio del
dolor los lugareños responsabilizan de
lo ocurrido a las autoridades
maestro mansión que nunca es una zona
que no tiene captación de agua las
autoridades no hubieren aquí hacer su
parte es parte de lo que está pasando
tome esto memphis con quien aguante hace
por el momento se mantiene el estado de
alerta en el área el número de muertos
ya supere el centenar y entre ellos hay
al menos 13 menores de edad
en ecuador la asamblea nacional aprobó
la despenalización del aborto en casos
de violación la medida permite la
interrupción del embarazo hasta la
semana número 12 en el caso de mujeres
mayores de edad que habiten en ciudades
y hasta la semana 16 en menores de edad
o mujeres que habiten en zonas rurales
la corte constitucional había aprobado
en abril de 2021 la despenalización del
aborto por violación pero legislativo
ecuatoriano debía reglamentar
vamos ahora hasta nicaragua donde
continúan los juicios contra opositores
del gobierno de daniel ortega este
jueves se conoció que el periodista
miguel mendoza fue condenado a nueve
años de prisión al tiempo que fue
inhabilitado para ejercer cargos
públicos el reportero un reconocido
crítico del ejecutivo de ortega es uno
de los 46 opositores detenidos previo a
las elecciones de noviembre en las que
el mandatario obtuvo su cuarto período
consecutivo
previamente conversamos con esmeralda
arosemena de troitiño
comisionada de la cdh y relatora para
nicaragua esto fue lo que nos dijo no
hay no hay forma de de
identificar que hay un tipo específico
porque cuando se dice de una manera tan
abierta
y las personas están siendo juzgadas por
cometer menoscabo a la integridad
nacional ya las conductas en el derecho
penal tienen que ser típicas es decir
identificadas
antijurídicas y que haya esa posibilidad
de culpar pero en esa apertura eso le
llamamos los delitos
en blanco porque no hay una norma real
para la efectividad de un proceso que
identifique esa conducta decir que vamos
a condenar una persona porque se
pronunció en una de las redes sociales
ya cuáles son los elementos y por eso el
tema de
en un juicio con de vido proceso con
garantías judiciales y ese es el llamado
durante su primera audiencia ante la
corte suprema de justicia del
expresidente de honduras juan orlando
hernández escuchó los cargos por
narcotráfico que le imputa a eeuu el
mandatario aseguró que sintió miedo
durante el procedimiento luego de que a
las afueras del recinto seguidores y
detractores estuvieran a punto de
enfrentarse con esta audiencia se inicia
el proceso de solicitud de extradición
la próxima está programada para el 16 de
marzo
seguimos con noticias de la región la
comunidad internacional se comprometió a
donar 600 millones de dólares a haití
fondos con los que se espera financiar
el primer año del programa de
reconstrucción de las infraestructuras
destruidas en el terremoto del pasado
agosto los nuevos aportes fueron
anunciados en una conferencia de
donantes organizada por el gobierno
haitiano en colaboración con la onu el
primer ministro de haití fue el audi
agradeció a la comunidad internacional
afirmando que la cifra recaudada supera
las expectativas que tenía el gobierno
en otras noticias el kobe 19 vuelve a
encender las alarmas en hong kong las
autoridades reportaron que los casos se
han multiplicado por 60 en lo que va del
mes por lo que están considerando un
testeo masivo obligatorio en las últimas
24 horas fueron reportados 6 mil 116
contagios una cifra que supera en 1800
la del miércoles andrés granadillo tiene
los detalles
un sistema de salud al borde del colapso
los hospitales de hong kong están
desbordados debido a la variante omicron
los enfermos deben esperar bajo el frío
invierno
no sabía que teníamos que esperar fuera
pensaba que estaríamos esperando dentro
del departamento de urgencias
está sintiendo fiebre fiebre y un poco
de fiebre y tuve un contacto cercano con
un paciente con kobe 19
el récord de infecciones en 24 horas fue
superado este jueves con 6 mil 116 casos
antes de la última ola el territorio
había registrado poco más de 12.000
contagios desde el comienzo de la
pandemia los expertos afirman que el
número diario podría aumentar a 28.000
en marzo pero los residentes de la isla
no creen que se puedan tomar las mismas
medidas que toma china continental creo
que las medidas de control de china
continental pueden no ser adecuadas para
hong kong las tasas de vacunación entre
los adultos de 70 a 79 años llegan al
43% la cifra de mayores de 80 que
optaron por vacunarse solo es del 26 por
ciento antes de la llegada de omicron
los pacientes serán tratados en salas de
aislamiento y los contactos cercanos
serán enviados a lugares de cuarentena
las escuelas los gimnasios los cines y
la mayoría de los lugares públicos están
cerrados y muchos empleados de oficina
trabajan desde casa en la burbuja de los
juegos olímpicos de beijing por el
contrario por primera vez desde el
comienzo de las competencias no se
registraron casos
en la vecina japón tras meses de
restricciones para los viajeros las
autoridades decidieron reducir los
controles fronterizos ante la baja de
casos y las críticas de empresas e
instituciones educativas el país ha
dejado de recibir 150.000 estudiantes
extranjeros debido a la pandemia además
de este alivio también se reducirá el
tiempo de cuarentena obligatoria para
los viajeros a sólo 3 días
y desde hoy durante cuatro meses se
podrá contemplar el manuscrito del
principito en francia concretamente en
el museo de las artes decorativas de
parís es la primera vez en la historia
que el original de esta obra maestra de
antoine dodson texu perry se expone en
el país de origen del autor los detalles
en el siguiente informe
quien no he leído escuchado o al menos
oído hablar del principito la obra
maestra de la literatura que cuenta la
historia de un niño y su viaje
intersideral
suntech super y escribió el libro en
nueva york' en 1942 y fue editado en
eeuu en inglés y en francés al año
siguiente en francia la editorial
gallimard lo publicó en 1946 ahora
cientos de dibujos acuarelas y
manuscritos han salido de la colección
estadounidense que posee los originales
desde 1968 y se exhiben por primera vez
en francia
se trata de varios esbozos pruebas donde
vemos al principito con un perro con un
loro y en ausencia del famoso zorro toda
la búsqueda estilística de suntech
superí era desconocida lo que es muy
conmovedor es ver hasta qué punto
necesitaba el dibujo para expresarse en
principio se le considera escritor y
aviador y ahora descubrimos que también
es dibujante
como
el escritorio aviador desapareció
durante una misión en el mediterráneo'
en 1944 y no conoció el éxito planetario
de su obra convertida en un clásico y
traducida a 498 lenguas una vez
hay ediciones en lenguas con muy pocos
hablantes como el vasco el idioma de un
pueblo ruso o el rapa nui el lenguaje de
la isla de pascua es la última
traducción conocida del principito hasta
la fecha
los estudiosos de la obra de suntech
superan y aseguran que el éxito de 'el
principito' se debe a su mensaje
humanista y universal que invita en
todos los rincones del mundo a
reflexionar sobre la cuestión del exilio
a ustedes les agradecemos su sintonía y
los invitamos a continuar con nosotros
que volvemos en unos momentos con más
aquí en france 24
[Música]